[Música]
no es difícil imaginar un mundo en el
que en cualquier momento usted y sus
conocidos podrían ser aniquilados sin
previo aviso con solo pulsar un botón
esta fue la realidad para millones de
personas Durante los 45 años posteriores
a la Segunda Guerra Mundial conocidos
Como la Guerra Fría mientras los Estados
Unidos y la unión soviética se
enfrentaban cada uno sabía que el otro
tenía armas nucleares para destruirlo
y la destrucción nunca fue tan inminente
como durante los 13 días de la crisis de
los misiles en Cuba en 1961 Estados
Unidos trató de derribar sin éxito al
nuevo gobierno comunista de Cuba ese
intento fallido conocido como Bahía de
cochinos convenció a Cuba de buscar
ayuda en la Unión soviética
el Primer Ministro soviético Nikita
crochef estaba feliz de cumplir un
despliegue nuclear secreto de misiles a
Cuba para proteger la isla y
contrarrestar la amenaza de misiles
estadounidenses en Italia y Turquía
para cuando la inteligencia de los
Estados Unidos descubrió el plan los
materiales para crear los misiles ya
estaban en el lugar en una reunión de
emergencia el 16 de octubre de 1962 los
asesores militares pidieron un ataque
aéreo a los sitios de misiles y la
invasión de La isla pero el presidente
John F Kennedy anunció el 22 de octubre
que la marina de los Estados Unidos
interceptaría todos los envíos a Cuba
hubo solo un problema el bloqueo naval
fue considerado un acto de guerra
a pesar de que el presidente lo llamó
una cuarentena que no bloqueaba las
necesidades básicas los soviéticos no
apreciaron la distinción en una
indignada carta a Kennedy crusher
escribió la violación de la libertad de
usar aguas internacionales y espacio
aéreo internacional es un acto de
agresión que empuja la humanidad al
Abismo de una guerra mundial de misiles
nucleares
Entonces se produjeron los seis días más
intensos de la Guerra Fría mientras
Estados Unidos exigía la eliminación de
los misiles Cuba y la unión soviética
insistían que solo se defendían y
mientras se seguían cargando las armas
Estados Unidos se preparaba para una
posible invasión el 27 de octubre un
avión espía pilotado por el mayor rudolf
Anderson fue derribado por un misil
soviético el mismo día una carga impactó
un submarino soviético nuclear desde un
buque de la marina de los Estados Unidos
que intentaba hacerlo emerger
los comandantes del submarino sin
comunicación pensaban que la guerra
había comenzado y se disponían a lanzar
un torpedo nuclear tres agentes debían
tomar esa decisión por unanimidad el
capitán y el oficial político
autorizaron el lanzamiento pero basili
arquívop el segundo al mando se negó su
decisión salvó el día Y quizá al mundo
pero la crisis no había terminado por
primera vez en la historia los militares
de los Estados Unidos pasaron a Def con
dos la disposición de defensa a un paso
de la guerra nuclear con los misiles
nucleares a punto de lanzarse El reloj
del juicio final se situó en un minuto
para la medianoche pero la diplomacia
prosiguió en Washington DC el procurador
general Robert Kennedy se reunió en
secreto con el embajador soviético
anatolyn tras intensas negociaciones
llegaron a la siguiente propuesta
Estados Unidos eliminaría sus misiles de
Turquía e Italia y prometía no invadir
Cuba A cambio de La retirada soviética
de Cuba bajo inspección de la ONU
concluida la reunión dobrinin envió un
cable a Moscú diciendo que el tiempo era
esencial y no se debía perder la
oportunidad y a las nueve del día
siguiente llegó un mensaje de crochef
anunciando que retirarían los misiles
soviéticos de Cuba la crisis había
terminado Aunque criticado en su momento
por sus respectivos gobiernos por
negociar con el enemigo el análisis
histórico contemporáneo muestra gran
admiración por la capacidad de Cruz chef
y Kennedy de resolver diplomáticamente
la crisis pero la lección inquietante
fue que un leve error de comunicación un
comandante en una fracción de segundo
podría haber frustrado sus esfuerzos de
no ser por la valiente decisión de
Basilio
esta crisis reveló lo frágiles que son
los políticos humanos en comparación con
el poder aterrador que pueden
desencadenar
Ted es una organización sin fines de
lucro considera apoyar nuestra misión de
proporcionar materiales educativos
gratuitos de alta calidad mediante
donaciones en patreon
[Música]